although covet 19 has largely limited
trouble between countries
a new idea is being put into practice
that will allow some more freedom of
movement within certain regions
they're known as travel bubbles two or
more countries regional states or
provinces
that have successfully curtailed the
coronavirus
can create a bubble this allows people
who live within the bubble
to travel freely within its borders and
not have to self-quarantee
estonia latvia and lithuania created one
in the baltics
in atlantic canada the provinces
of new brunswick nova scotia prince
edward island and newfoundland and
labrador have a bubble for its residents
which came into effect on july 3rd
altogether the atlantic provinces have
about 1500 confirmed cases
and about 68 deaths dr jennifer russell
is the chief medical officer of health
for new brunswick
it's not uncommon for us to um
collaborate uh
regionally like this um but i think from
a comfort level with the numbers being
what they are and the way that um
there's kind of a corridor from
ontario and quebec obviously the quebec
border with new brunswick
we are the gatekeepers basically for pei
in nova scotia
so it made a lot of sense uh with
respect to how
things were going in the atlantic
provinces compared to quebec and ontario
australia and new zealand had been
considering a travel bubble as well
but in early july new zealand prime
minister
jacinta ardern said that the plan would
be re-examined because of a new
outbreak in the australian state of
victoria
meanwhile singapore and malaysia are set
to launch their travel bubble on august
10th
dr russell says the response to the
opening of the atlantic
canada bubble has been positive
particularly because people don't have
to repeatedly self-isolate
when they travel from one area to
another
there's a sense of relief around again
gaining that extra freedom
and and again we try to be cautiously
optimistic about this because this
pandemic is not going away
and there will always be risk outside of
our borders and so the travel imported
cases will continue to happen we still
have to be ready for that
and in the meantime again be vigilant
about testing be vigilant about wearing
masks when you can't
physically distance really trying to do
low-risk activities
you know in terms of being outdoors and
versus indoors and then if you are going
to be doing activities that are indoors
and have larger numbers of people then
again
doing as much as you can to be cautious
around those types of risks and keeping
your number of close contacts
low
you